hi I'm Conan O'Brien I just want to say
good news ladies I am Groot in the
streets and I am baby Groot in the
sheets
[Applause]
wait that's not good I mean you're cute
and yeah I know I know exactly
hey Comic Con is in full swing all the
big events are happening at Hall H
that's the place to be case you're
wondering the H stands for holy [ __ ]
that's a long line
[Applause]
a celebration I know there are a lot of
great panels at Comic Con a lot of great
panels yeah thanks for allying that
concept the the creators of Westworld
held a Q&A today interesting yeah yeah
it was uh yeah it was just them asking
the audience can someone please tell us
what the hell our show was about this
some big idea all the big stars are at
comic-con in fact the cast of Game of
Thrones will be here tomorrow night
here's a tip here's a tip if you're
coming and they offer you wine whatever
you do do not drink it speaking of Game
of Thrones one of the big moments in the
history of that series is when Arya
Stark is told a girl is no one yeah
coincidentally that's also be new slogan
for the Republican Party
you've got to work a little politics
into this thing
it can't all be aware of them make
believe it is so great that all of you
came to comic-con because this place is
not cheap it is not cheap I heard this
and I couldn't believe it
the average cost to attend comic-con is
1603 dollars that's true that's true
yeah so finally a chance to spend the
money you all save by not going to prom
[Applause]
we're so friends yeah I love that
everyone's like hey we're getting a free
pop figure
[Music]
or are you yeah people the car like you
better have over here that's the only
reason we came to this piece of [ __ ]
you